A while ago I made a video called "How I Feel About Dick Pics."
And there were a lot of requests in the comment section to also talk about naked selfies.
Should you send nude photos?
Well, there's a lot of reasons not to.
Yeah, you trust him now.  But you don't know how things will end.
If they ever got out, you'd be screwed.
Ugh.  This takes forever.  You have to find the right lighting and the right angle--it's a waste of time.  Trust me.
Just hire a photographer.
But then there are the reasons a lot of us want to.
I'm in a long distance relationship.
I don't think it's a big deal--it's like customized porn.
When I'm 90, I'm going to frame those "puppies" and give them to my grandkids
so they can see that their grandma was one smoking hot cookie back in her day.
#TBT
And of course, we've all heard the Do's and Don'ts with taking these photos.
Never include your face.
Only send them to partners you trust and are in a serious relationship with.
Before you send them, make sure you imagine what would happen if he betrayed your trust and leaked all
those photos on the internet and they were up there forever.
If you're okay with that...go ahead.
Should you take nude photos?  If you're not an adult, the answer is no.
If you are an adult, that's totally your call.
All I can hope is that you take it as seriously as you would a tattoo or adopting an animal
because we live in an age where hacking is common, laws need to be created for revenge porn,
and what lives on the internet stays on the internet.
Have I personally sent naked photos?  Yes.
When I was younger and I was stupid, when I'm older and I'm still a little stupid.
Mostly to boyfriends I've been in long term relationships with.
And honestly, as an adult, I don't see anything wrong with nude photos.
I don't see a problem with it.
It only becomes a concern when people who aren't suppose to see these photos see them.
I mean that is a scary and humiliating prospect.
Especially for a public figure.
High school kids have killed themselves over their naked photos being leaked.
It can be a huge fucking deal.
So the next time anyone asks you for a nude photo, just be aware of what the worst case scenario could be.
And if you're cool with that, grab your selfie-stick and go to town.
Unless you're underage, then don't you dare.
I'm Anna Akana.  Stay awesome Gotham.
Thanks so much to Squarespace for sponsering today's episode.
(Click!)
You can start building your website today at Squarespace.com.
All the sites are professionally designed regardless of your skill level and there's absolutely no coding required.
The tools are intuitive and easy to use and you get a free domain if you sign up for a year.
You can start your free trial at Squarespace.com
Don't forget to use the offer code "Anna" at checkout for 10% off.
Squarespace, you should.
Growing up, nothing was more magical or mysterious than the act of sex.
You know I used to think that if your nipples touched a guy's nipples you were insta-pregnant!
Whoa, whoa.  Gettin' a little close there.
I don't have any nipple tassels so be careful.